hey yo well good morning gamers it's
minecraft day
heck yeah my favorite day i love
minecraft
i am legit addicted to this game i am
having so
much fun look at this look at my farm
it's epic
and look at my oh my god
i feel like this probably goes against
some rules and regulations all right
who's hungry
who's hungry there you go there you go
have it all eat as much as you can
now the reason i did this is because we
actually need to start murdering them
because we're going a god damn all right
i'm just gonna kill
i'm sorry peter look away ah
i need your meat i'm sorry they're
escaping
stop them oh god what have i done oh god
oh okay
all right the children gets to what are
you doing in my boat
okay that's awesome you guys can stay in
the boat that's
oh you're friends with jurgen you can
stay why do i even have a farm this is
too look at all the children
you wouldn't kill a child felix no i
wouldn't
oh my god all right okay
it's oh jargon jargon sorry sorry
sorry sorry all right the kids gets to
live i'm that gracious but i do need
their meat because today
we are going on epic adventure
that's right everyone we have these
treasure maps and we're gonna go and
find
where it is it looks like it's probably
pretty goddamn far
epic that is the cutest thing i have
ever seen in my entire life
oh yeah i made some uh improvement to
the house as well
uh got this new carpet got this new
terrace
it's pretty epic it's whatever oh yeah
and these bad guys
attacked me so i put their banner on our
epic tree of life
okay jurgen has to stay on this
adventure actually maybe i should bring
him oh god it's too scary
so we are the tiny dot on the map
that's so far dude is this one nearer
oh look it is it changing it is changing
oh god this is so complicated dude all
right we'll get jurgen for this one
all right jurgen let's ride
so we have to ride this direction
question mark hey jurgen's friend hello
jurgen's friend
this is epic oh god we're gonna need a
boat aren't we uh or maybe not
so all the people in this village
disappeared it i don't know why
it's not like i was trying to blow up
their house or anything but turtle is
still here hello turtle
and stone per person is still here hello
stone person
so now wait this is now we're going
south how do we go in on the map
surely this should be the way or is it
this way
okay wait so we need to go west we need
to go this way
ah ah jay baleeba oh god damn it
yeah it's this way no it's not
okay this way i don't know how this
works okay i've never done this
i'm a gamer i it's all gamer intuition
that's all i got
i haven't shown everything i've been
doing i've been playing offline for
hours and hours and i'm so
hooked on minecraft but i haven't done
any adventure so i'm excited now
to go on epic okay this is working i
think
no we're just going up again aren't we
what about this way
i think we might have to get a boat i
don't like this
will you be a good boy uh jurgen
we're gonna we're gonna do it like this
stay oh god stay
okay how did i not bring a shovel to a
goddamn treasure hunt
map hunting thing this is what i get for
forgetting
everything jurgen stop wandering off
my god i've already lost your brother
now down the hall you go just be a good
boy and stay
in the hole here i have a flower don't
look at me like that i'm sorry i have to
that's right well there's another city
there there's another city
all right jurgen don't worry i know what
i'm doing
oh yeah ah my boat where did my boat go
there you are oh i feel bad for jurgen i
really
do why do i care maybe we can trade with
these people
maybe this city is less lousy than the
other one
the city is being under attack all right
then i won't go then
okay so now it would make sense that we
just need to go in this direction
at least if you ask me is it possible
that the treasure is just underwater
i think that might be a yes there's one
there's light under the water
is that santa claus i can't see i don't
have my glasses oh my god there's so
many cities
whoa the map the map is appearing
what is this what is this it's a ship in
the sand
question mark okay let's remember where
we parked our boat
is there a treasure map in here i think
i need dark wood
i don't remember why i needed dark wood
but i think i do
nothing is going to stop me from getting
this treasure oh god i think it's by the
city
[Music]
oh that's perfect i'll just place
torches so i can remember how
ah
it's sand zombies
and so he ventured deep in the night
this is just like a lot thing am i right
oh god damn it i think i need the boat
or do i i don't have my glasses i'm
practically flying
wow what's that okay we need to cross
let's try thixy okay
oh damn i swim fast underwater
okay we're going we're getting close
gamers what is that
that's my other nether portal what
that's crazy
hey he's got a golden armor
stop stop stupid baby i i will kill a
child i don't care
god these ones wow he rich boy
hype beast okay alright gamers we're
gonna find this treasure
if it's the last thing i'll ever do so i
see my direction right
where i'm facing it's kinda hard to this
is faced away from it
all right and this is face towards it
let's see how my
orientation skills will pan out
that's what i wanted to do okay should
be
somewhere here no problem right
how in the gods earth am i going to find
this game may work
yeah oh looks like sun is almost up
gamers
oh that's me once that gaming week is
over
gaming week for life
all right so i need a lot of dirt oh
look at me i got arrows inside me
i need a lot of dirt so we can make an
air bubble thing oh my god what if we
find
gucci pants in the treasure that would
be
so awesome
how do you make an air bubble listen i
don't have time for
boat people
[Music]
go back to the swamp shrink oh and the
music kicks in at the perfect
time and you're having an epic adventure
looking for minecraft
okay so i don't know if this is the most
effective way to do it
knowing myself most no no it isn't why
is there no scuba equipment in minecraft
they had nine years to add it get out of
my way
what an irony to dig up treasure map
we have to build that's called a paradox
my minecraft children
it actually makes it easier with sand
because then i can just drop them drop
them faster minecraft i ain't got time
notch
i feel like this is the time where my
audience is just cringing and being like
what is he doing
listen i don't know okay i'm not
pretending that i know
all i do know is like subscribe for more
epic
minecraft okay come on forgot the corner
straight down here should do it okay
let's go gamers
hopefully we don't drown so how do i
know how deep it goes
oh i'm drowning i'm drowning i'm
drowning gamers pewdiepie didn't
pewdiepie then oh god i'm opposite
drowning
can i zoom in at least i feel like i can
smell it
must be here somewhere maybe just dig
deeper
question mark my name is jeff like where
is it where is it
god damn it jurgen is waiting for me
he's going to be so
pissed dude maybe i can make an airlock
underneath the water
and that will make it easier for me to
just mine
all right dolphin i don't have time for
you am i being pranked
is it a thing maybe it's like has to be
surface level and i'm just digging super
deep
it's harder to find these map than
diamonds
okay i give up i'm starting to think
there was no treasure
oh my god but at least we had fun
i got them and the llamas are gone all
right well at least we can explore what
we we're gonna do last episode whoa it's
like a pyramid
that's awesome can i go what in the
world is that
this place makes zero sense whoa look at
this
this time no traps okay
here we go gamers no stepping on traps
okay
gamer learn from my mistakes diamonds
oh my god diamond
i run horse armor jurgen is going to be
so happy oh my craft
oh
this is better than any treasure the
trip was worth it after all
oh god felix maybe you shouldn't be
greedy you literally cannot carry
anything else
okay gamers let's go what if jurgen
starved to death in the hole no
oh please please be in the hole
please be in the oh my god you're in the
hole you're again
yeah it worked did you have a good time
dude i got a carrot eat the carrot how
do i give him the carrot
all right cool well anyway i have a
present for you
oh my god oh my god you look
so good you're good you don't mind if i
have the carrot do you thank you
what up cows oh my god what am i gonna
do about you guys i didn't realize they
would get so many
all right i'm making a diamond pickaxe
because we're gonna go on epic gaming
adventure
it's crazy how much time you can spend
in this game seriously
all right i'm working on the powered
rails guys please don't judge
me so i'm gonna get some more nether i
forgot what it's called
we need to mine more of this
which is always the most fun ever all
right so we have obsidian
so i want to see what it's like if you
head out
in the other direction because i have
leather i have epic stuff to trade with
the villagers
can i kill that thing i don't have an
arrow all right time to make a bridge
yeah god damn it ah
whoa what is that what is that like a
frog is it dangerous
hello let me be your friend it's so cute
oh god it's coming towards me safe
distance
safe distance all right i'm gonna kill
it it is decided
you're again you will not believe this
sorry you can't come it isn't 100
safe i've never done this okay we're
gonna kill the giant
frog thing maybe he just wants to hug me
i'm not gonna find it hello
where'd he go i wanted to kill it whoa
whoa whoa whoa
look at that whoa it's so big oh there
it is
oh jesus
all right okay all right okay it's a
battle the battle
begins i can't shoot
oh ah this is bad
uh it's all right i brought don't panic
i brought water bucket
it doesn't work i brought plenty of food
i'm ready i may you may have gotten the
upper hand
mister quick scope
quick scope quick scope
oh hit them oh
you did you did ah
that was easy dude easy mode you see
that pig
all right i'm gonna find that demon frog
now have i mind those
i don't think i have what are those
[ __ ] ass oh it's over oh it's over
not like this
[Music]
no you're again you will not believe
what just happened
you be quiet oh god i hit my sheep
i've sunk in so yeah i lost everything
that's epic gamer rage quit
i'm so sick of dying this is for jurgen
ah
you can run but you can't hide i'd feel
bad if jurgen wasn't dead
there needs to be suffering in this
world
so uh apparently one block into the
nether round
is eight blocks in the other round so if
i walk like this
i open up opportunity now hopefully
all my stuff isn't gone i count on maybe
some of my stuff
maybe just not all of my stuff trying to
have a pma over here okay
back to level four that's oh
my god
yes oh i got my diamond pickaxe back
oh my god i had you know what i had a
feeling
so many of you have said it told me that
you can enter
a quote like a text and then you won't
lose your stuff if you die but i feel
like that beats the purpose all right
we're doing it survival i'm a pro player
okay another thing i read is apparently
if i mine
those then i can breathe on the water
question mark
it's the hottest day in uk i have two
lights headed
on my face so the green screen will work
why am i torturing myself okay another
thing you guys told me was to bring up
the brightness oh my god that is so much
nicer
see i listened to you guys too why do
you tell me to do all these awful things
instead
we had a trust and that trust is broken
forever
whoa what is this two series saying
beefy fist did i just try to mine with
the melon oh my god you can
i'm mining with a melon bros i keep
meloning
all right let's build our little portal
over here
one two this will literally be the
furthest we've ever gone
i'm actually kind of scared plus we're
really low down oh
god what's gonna happen dude look how
long it's taking all right gamers i am
all gamed out smash like subscribe
for more minecraft and i see you guys
next episode
bye what you never played two for
simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my
opinion but give it a try and then you
can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]